direction un célèbre café restaurant de
la capitale à la rencontre du casting du
film la lutte des classes voire du
couperet que n'étant pas sur la fiche je
parlerai beaucoup moins quand il s'agit
de son enfant et de sa scolarité que
faire et quels publics ou établissements
privés c'est à cette question que doit
répondre le couple formé par leïla
bekhti et edouard baer écoutez le sel de
la classe de sel quoi c'est le blanc tu
me dises à moi en plus
ripley la mixité pour ce soit de nexity
pour ce soit de la mixité si ça n'est
pas la mixité ça n'est pas de mixité tu
vois idéalisme cynisme ou réalisme sofia
et paul vont devoir choisir
et pour ça ils peuvent compter sur le
lobbying d'un directeur d'école publique
incarné par ramzy bedia entretien avec
l'irrésistible trio de la lutte des
classes
bon les gars sont je crois que c'est bon
on l'a dit la victime orbey ramzy bedia
merci d'être là dans cet ordre là je
crois c'est lors de l'affiché tu as dû
te veut pas dire qu'on est mieux qu
ramzy bedia simplement que le parent
d'apparition à l'écran un écran et par
ordre d'importance des rôles ce pas
brillé à leïla bekhti il vraiment au
sommet de son art et leïla bekhti qu'on
n'a pas vue depuis la règle du jeu
depuis hambourg le coq de coil cocteau
rebours depuis le parrain 5
et puis je crois qu'à un moment
j'attends un moment de maturité je peux
toujours et je danse grâce à michel
leclerc seront le point sur lequel nous
allons revenir de droit qui vient en
générosité par passion alors qu'il est
habitué à tête d'affiché lee l'accès de
servir par amour du projet et de ce film
vraiment des autres comédiens qui a dans
ce film aussi on voit si tu quand même
le fibre fait c'est la lutte des classes
et c'est une vraie comédie sociale qui
abordent des sujets dans l'air du temps
comme la mixité le port du voile la
laïcité l'harcèlement scolaires aussi
c'est ce qui vous a plu dans ce film oui
voilà c'est l'histoire d'un couple
normal qu'ils se posent des questions
assez normal je pense qu'on s'est tous
posé la question de savoir est ce que
est ce qu'on reste fidèle à
l'environnement social dans lequel on a
grandi
ou au contraire est-ce qu'on on le met
dans une école privée parce qu'on a
l'impression que ce sera mieux pour cet
enfant et que et ça raconte aussi
quelque chose c'est que ya pas de morale
a asséné quelques chocolats d'abord les
enfants les thèmes de la cantine
voudrais savoir qui est en situation
d'arabité pigmentaire approbation
musulmane qui mange du cochon rami c'est
quand même un mot à mot sur ce sur ce
personnage mais en fait j'ai pas
composer ce perso je le connais c'est
moi ce mets ta vraie et grandi dans des
quartiers un peu défavorisés aussi est
il y en a plein des comme ça et
d'ailleurs c'est à ces gars là moi ça
m'a énormément touché que michel me
propose ce personnage là parce que ce
personnage là pour moi et ultra
important essayer des personnages qu'on
voit de moins en moins et pourtant il y
en a encore et il faut aider ces mecs là
et quand le les moyens techniques ne
suivent plus parce que les locaux ne
sont pas techniquement comme celle du
16e ou celle de neuilly et ben il ya
encore ces hommes là et ces femmes là
qui sont des moteurs qui font tenir les
flics il faut aimer la république à ses
enfants et qui c'est je trouve fabuleux
ces mecs là j'étais très fier
d'interpréter un de ses ancien monsieur
là que c'est super c'est qu'on voit
presque jamais c'est que le système ne
marche jamais moi j'en suis convaincu
c'est les gens qui sauve tout moi je
suis épaté de voir rami jouer des ça ne
s'invente pas l'autorité naturelle
programme si l'aca et à part dire 'ça y
rajoutant entrain de gaulle en tentant
un sourire une douceur mais d'abord il
faut être dans la vie il faut arriver à
un âge pour pouvoir jouer ça je trouve
ça formidable comme étaient des mecs à
l'époque comme jean poiret comme la
charité et dans la comédie dans
l'autorité naturelle
le film pose aussi cette question ou
mettre ses enfants à l'école est ce que
c'est le domaine dans le public ou dans
le privé
j'ai vécu la chose inverse parce que moi
j'étais donc un petit robot du site et
que mes parents ont mis à l'école privée
est pas à l'école publique de
de gt de gennevilliers pourquoi penses
disant ignorer les raisons qui sont
expliquées dans le meilleur avenir il
sera c'est pour ça que ce film me parle
terriblement parce que c'est pour toutes
ces raisons mais c'est de l'autre côté
nous céder arabe qu'on dit non tu vas
pas dans les écoles dallara tu vas des
écoles catholiques ou chez gm a pris
hier je vous salue marie avant de manger
c'est celle inverse vos enfants alors je
m'occupe n'entrent pas dans ce moule
votre fils dans le film tomtom les big
incroyable aussi ça s'est passé comment
il était comment lui face à vous il est
un mandataire d'augmenter non non non
non il était en fait ce que ce qui m'a
touché et est quelquefois on le voit pas
forcément chez tous les enfants acteurs
c'est que ce n'était pas un enfant
acteur ça reste un enfant dont qui
venait le matin ils s'amusaient et du
coup il était moi je les trouve fou de
vérité dans le film quand je peux payer
les achats mais moi si tous les
compagnons te dis que le privé tu vas
pas aimé c'est tout propre c'est tout
notarié qui dépasse les revient mais non
et puis la fille était formidable deux
filles elle est géniale et l'idée de
cette adolescente qui hurlent des choses
très sympas moi j'adore ça je connais ça
dans la vie le dire sur un ton odieux
des choses je jouais dans j'adore
tchitchao est une super présentatrice
d'une très bonne élève est il votre
journaliste formidable c'est un
compliment il a les gens croient qu'ils
ont dit un truc odieux et pas du tout
alors que si vous dit très gentiment je
trouve que tout c'est de la merde en
quoi il a dit un truc très sympa quand
je t'ai offert un très beau des
tendances à hurler des choses sympas
ne crois-tu au dieu merci à tous les
trois juste juste avant de se quitter
cette phrase que votre personnage dit
dans le film que je trouve sublime vous
vous dites que vous ne voulez pas que
votre fils réussisse dans la vie mais
qu'il réussisse sa vie sauve à toute la
nuance
abbas et les et sujets de philosophie
co2 des sujets de bac
oui c'est ça c'est lui
le moment personnages et puis cette
famille là c'est pas gentil obsédé par
la réussite sociale l'extérieur
financière et de changer de statut c'est
des gens qui croient qu'il faut qu'on
coule il faut être quelqu'un quoi mais
au sens quelqu'un plein avec des
convictions des raies sont imaginaires à
soi c'est un petit bateau pirate cette
famille c'est ce qui est super c'est
vraiment ça on est on est du petit
pirate des petits pirates bien venir 126
mètres et des vents souffleront je veux
repartir